speaking of machine like things uh we
have been shapiro here um with this uh
with this video
this is this is let's see this is only
11 this is only 11 seconds look it's so
good but let's let's give the audience a
little background on this because it is
very important that the audience knows
why this person in the audience um does
the thing that they do and says the
thing they need to say because ben
shapiro weirdly has on his show
um has said some some really
things that really weren't like
instigated about his wife and her vagina
right like we are we are almost
two years in to this initial moment
happening right i think when he made the
comments i mean when he made a comment
about his wife
like right so the song comes out you
know whap what has [ __ ] right right
right you're talking about the cardi b
song where are you so there's some
[ __ ] in this house yeah [ __ ] in this
house there's some [ __ ] in this house
is that the song yeah yeah yeah i did my
own version that was about uh cicadas oh
okay you know okay but uh she releases
that song in the summer of 2020. so it's
like you know
we're going through the pandemic yeah
there's only you know [ __ ] in this
house because we're locked in the house
right exactly you know and everyone
loves that
song
i
mean
it offends really fragile white men
right but most people like the song [ __ ]
which stands for wet ass [ __ ] yeah it's
a it's a banger yeah right you know it's
fun it really piss you know what pisses
them off the music video that's what
really oh yeah because they're going to
go over and watch like oh there must it
must be really sexy because it talks
about wet ass [ __ ] and these fragile
white men go over
and it's a bunch of you know half naked
and they just freak out probably they
just freaked out there's nothing wet or
[ __ ] right oh my god right right it
just confuses the sh that's probably why
they're mad about it yeah so she
releases that song the internet goes
whoa this is crazy this is cool we like
the song blah blah blah
ben shapiro just throws himself into the
conversation republicans have a tendency
to drag themselves
through the mud willingly
they are like they just throw themselves
into like the topic and everyone's like
nobody
ever called for your opinion but now
that you're here oh right
that's an awful take and you just like
almost incriminated yourself and reveal
something about your own personal life
that now people are just gonna make more
fun of and now it's two years later and
that [ __ ] is not getting old anytime
soon and it lives in this 11 seconds oh
just ma i mean it is just just sweet
sweet family i don't know who is but
they deserve a medal oh you know they're
the hero of 2022. well you should see
the look on the face
of this person when they say this
because they know they know like
oh this is it baby this is all i got
this if someone's got this and so
confident they don't hesitate they know
exactly what they're gonna say their
dismount is great the landing is great
um even the person holding the
microphone it takes them several seconds
to even know what the hell is going on
and even the crowd is like
right so tell us about tell us about
what ben shapiro in kind of a nutshell
ben shapiro said about his wife's vagina
when he was commenting on the womp song
because he was saying basically that he
did [ __ ] aren't wet is that what he
was saying i mean yeah
you know he is
that [ __ ] are dry right and his and
he doesn't get his wife wet right and
his that that is not a thing that
happens yeah that's not a thing that
happened his wife is a doctor and was
like totally normal totally normal you
know
totally i i don't get wet you know right
so she told him this yeah yeah and
benjamin i don't know if he really
processed what she said
and maybe she was like hint wink wink
like
uh maybe the song brought this up like
at their house like he's like you know
back
i've heard this song wet ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
and back a while ago you were stating
something and like this is what brought
this this you know old thing up in in
their in their conversation right while
they were pro who knows they were
probably just eating cans of peas
doesn't seem like like that's what their
dinner would be is ben shapiro he just
he doesn't eat meals he's just like
eating peas or you know right so so
that's where well that's where the the
the dap came from which is dry ass [ __ ]
and people were now but i think his
original tweet if i look it up it says
also i discussed on the show my only
real concern is that the women involved
who apparently require a bucket and a
mop
get a
medical care they require
my doctor's wife differential diagnosis
bacterial vaginosis yeast infection and
trichomonas
trichomonasis so
it's uh he literally does not understand
art he does not understand
cardi b in that song is saying bucket
and a mop
like
like to describe to describe what is
happening in the song like the narrative
god forbid a woman is like oh my god i'm
really turned on and aroused by this
other person right right you know
whatever god forbid and
god forbid a woman loves sex i mean a
man loves sex all day long right right
but if a woman does it they're a threat
or a [ __ ] or whatever it is like
derogatory way so like god forbid it's
like this person's like oh my god i'm so
turned on [ __ ] open the floodgates
this person just like wrecked me right
now and then ben shapiro is like
uh
you need a bucket and a mop
my wife uh is
is the opposite right uh you know it's
like
it's you know without going into detail
about bench pharaoh's
dry ass [ __ ] situation right uh you
know
his
gap right
but i look at that i'm like oh you you
brought yourself into you decided to
commentate on this song
and what was happening
culturally and then you said uh
actually this seems like a real big
issue on just like uh in an infection or
some sort of a diagnosis my wife she
says that's not really a thing you know
right well you know i think what he's
saying here is women getting horny or
you know as you say what what did you
say real or i don't know what you're
correct getting correct getting wrecked
yeah which is great a woman getting
ready
yeah they're saying like god forbid this
person is really aroused and is showing
that they're wet and he goes uh actually
my wife said uh that it's a medical
condition and she probably has some sort
of infection a yeast infection or
bacterial and everyone's life
way too good you're way too good
and everyone's like ben why did you even
why did why did you even come in the
conversation like clearly someone's not
coming here and it's not going to be you
you know
well and my advice to you gabe is to
keep that voice down because that voice
may just dap
in your heart if you if you if you do
the binge beer away too much
you may actually
my wife has a dry ass [ __ ] uh
happy i'm so happy that vince appeared
that this happened because now we can
have this conversation right you know
without without ben shapiro doing this
stupid thing we can't have these
conversations
because again republicans
willingly drag themselves through the
[ __ ] right because they try to make some
point or like mansplain or just describe
like well my opinion my opinion matters
and then what ends up happening is
everyone goes no you're just dumb as
[ __ ] and you could not just read what
the song was talking about you took it
literally and took it as a bad thing
right when it is a good thing right and
it's art too she's trying to make a
description but i guess those rounds
have never experienced it don't
understand it right right
the best part here about this video is
here we are two years later because
really ben shapiro probably in his own
mind is like well we're way past the
whole dap thing we're way past that and
we are not past that and i don't think
we'll ever be passionate we'll never be
past it it's now he's speaking at some
kind of uh lecture series or something
and then the fred and linda allen yeah
i'm not sure what the hell that is i'm
not sure what the hell that is
but it sounds like you're looking it up
so so i'll let you look that up and and
to give us context um of of the speech
that he's giving but let's watch the
video here because it is a beautiful 11
seconds everyone uh keep your ears open
here
uh not for ben shapiro but the person
who speaks after him who is in the
audience who is speaking into a
microphone dysphoria which i listen to
that i use throughout the speech not
generally you sound like a bozo and you
get no [ __ ] and you can't even make
your wife wet bro so what's good
[Laughter]
like what's good and i was like
[Music]
so the first part the first part because
ben shapiro obviously is going at this
person or trans something which is which
is a standard thing that ben shapiro
does he'll go to these talks give these
lectures someone will say hey you have
this point of view however it's
incorrect because of this and then
benchmark goes actually uh based on
research and then it's like well that
research wasn't real and ben shapiro is
notorious he does it on uh joe rogan's
when he goes on that show he's notorious
for either
uh fabricating stats or he will
exaggerate them to prove his point so
every time he talks he's like well
actually there is a study done on family
learning and all this other [ __ ] like
you can literally just make fart sounds
and yeah yeah just as just as helpful
one of the best videos other than this
one now one of the i mean this has got
to be the best bench bureau video that's
out there
now now the second best venture bureau
is when he's describing uh ocean levels
rising he's like oh well the people in
florida can just sell their property
like ben if the [ __ ] house is under
water
no one like he clearly does not
understand like supply and demand like
this guy's video he's some kind of smart
[ __ ]
and he clearly does not understand let's
play while you're looking for that let's
play this one more time because like we
gotta see this one more time i use
throughout the speech not generally you
sound like a bozo and you get no [ __ ]
and you can't even make your wife wet
bro so what's good
and the entire crowd because
most of the crowd is there because they
love
shapiro like why would you go to like
you know i i've been saying the last
week uh our last three weeks every time
there's a trump around like i'd rather
eat a big bag of dog [ __ ] than go to a
trump rally but maybe there is cause if
someone would pass around a microphone
and give someone the the time to speak
at a trump rally maybe there is cause to
go to trump rally like this beautiful
person did at whatever kind of lecture
series this year yeah so uh oh yeah so
let me give you context quickly when i
looked it up it's uh it's part of the
shapiro lecture tour it's young
america's foundation
the fred and linda allen lecture series
uh
uh he's
fred allen is the owner and founder of
geosoils a
geotechnical consulting company in
southern california so it just looks
like uh they hosted him but it was part
of this
um
right right-wing fascist trying to play
right like they're part of normal
society amanda says um ben shapiro's
voice could dry up entire rivers
uh dapp um would make a great parody
song d says from facebook i'm sure
here's the thing i'm sure somebody
already made that song angela from
facebook wants us to play it again so
i'll play it one more time all right
i've got the other video ready to go
okay
go ahead and send me that link and we'll
we'll play this one one more time the
number one ben shapiro video out there
on the internet right now
until someone tops this one which i
don't know if you will here it is one
more time throughout the speech not
generally you sound like a bozo and you
get no [ __ ] and you can't even make
your wife
you can't help but laugh every single
time it's fantastic he's like bro bro
bro you're a boso
you can't even make your wife wet bro
bro bro oh my god it's it's fantastic
what's this one that you're gonna show
this is the one where he's talking about
the the this is the one where he's
talking about the uh
the water levels the water levels around
the world rise by by let's say five feet
over the next hundred years say ten feet
by the next hundred years and it puts
all the low-lying areas on the coast
underwater right which let's say all of
that happens you think that people
aren't going to just sell their homes
and move
[Laughter]
oh my god sell it to aquaman and